good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Monday where we have such a
[__] disgustingly important job to do
today which is
what karma is a guy on the Chiefs coming
straight home to me it's true we do that
is all forthcoming within the show
that's really all it's hard to pick
stories when like there's the one story
and then there's the other four Jackie I
feel sick
why do you feel sick L turd I feel sick
because I am sick I'm coming down with a
cold so if I feel Nas if I sound nasly
or angry that's why give us a little
sticky shoes would you my sticky sticky
isues you know it hasn't gotten to that
level yet like right now it's it's it's
sort of coming down throughout the night
I was like feeling myself get sicker and
sicker it was really kind of a dreadful
a dreadful evening of sleep so I'm just
kind of on one today I've had a morning
o I love when Jackie's on one you think
you're going to punch a CVS checkout
machine if there was one in
sight pow pow it's on it's on I'm
throwing hands I love that yeah no it
was rough and then also like I get
really bad scalp pain you ever get that
like when when I don't wash my hair yeah
yeah yeah so my hair was looking
gorgeous so I was like you know what let
me get myself Monday with my hair on the
show and then I'll wash it Monday night
but in the middle of the night it was
just hurting so much let's talk about
that is that I don't know and it hurts
like even more postpartum so when
Charlie like woke up at 6:30 to feed I
was like I have to get up and wash my
hair right now because I'm in so much
pain so then my day started at 6:30 with
Wasing my hair and then I wound up like
falling back asleep at like 7:30 it was
just and then I was and then I was like
woke up late and in a rush and had to
pump and it was just not my morning I
can't claim this morning there are so
many things about girlhood that like are
so unfair like periods I feel like we
talk about the obvious ones child birth
like why can't a man do that we don't
talk enough about the scalp pain like
what is that I don't know it's like your
nerve endings and I guess my scalp is
like extra tender right now I mean it
was a long time since I washed my hair
sure who cares but it shouldn't I should
have gotten this extra day I shouldn't
have had to get up at 6:00 a.m. to wash
my hair because that's how much pain I
was in well you look great thanks well
then I was like didn't have time to dry
my hair so it's in a slick back bun but
You' never know you never know you look
great I love when you're in a mood I
feel like it's usually me so I will be
you know the Jacks today and you will be
the cler well now that I'm in the chair
like I'm it's all done and I'm good and
we can go forth with the show but just
like getting to this chair was harder
than usual today you know when Mean
Girls when Katie Haron is like so mad
and reget says put it in the book yeah
put it in the chair yeah but no like now
I'm fine right no the chair heals all
yeah I just had to get to the chair but
the getting to the chair I did not fair
well so we have so much to talk about
today when it comes to pop culture but
we also have so much to talk about today
when it comes about us when it comes to
us cuz like we are important and we are
busy you know yeah is this me you
wanting me to ask you like how are you
what's new with you what do you want to
talk about not me if you if you wanted
to ask about me because I kind of had
like a crazy busy weekend okay Claudia
how are you doing what's new with you
how was your weekend it was so busy oh
my God it was like jam-packed Friday
night you were still here I hosted my
very first family shabus at my home it
was amazing to have just everyone there
except for Olivia she was dearly missed
but everyone in New York at my home I
feel like it was great it was great Ben
cooked a gorgeous meal the kids were
there like it was just it was really
what's the word um it filled my cup
beautiful and then I had a super early
morning on Saturday because I went to
Atlanta for the ug no not Atlanta I'm
sorry I keep saying that Athens for the
ug Old Miss game I was there um doing an
event with Estee Lauder and I don't do a
lot of like events on college campuses
and I don't feel like we're like huge
like with college students I just feel
like they're a little young so I was
like expecting like you know like 12
people to show up and like whatever oh
my God Jackie we have to move to Georgia
okay the toast is huge huge in Georgia I
love that they everybody came out it was
so much fun I really really put into
perspective for me like how much I
missed out on like a traditional college
experience you know it like looked so
fun yeah like this small town that when
you were driving through was so Charming
like these houses and I just know that
like you know professors live there and
they have like you know dinner parties
for their student like it was so
Collegiate and there was a big football
game which was even more Collegiate
because everybody was wearing the colors
and alumni came in and it was just so
cute like it was this whole life that I
never had yeah and what what's the
anti-Semitism like on on that college
campus I'm so glad you brought it up
because obviously it was top of mine for
me I was like what are what is everybody
doing here to battle anti-Semitism and I
didn't really think that there would be
like a lot of Jewish students but I
think maybe all of them came to the meet
and greet yeah um because they were like
it's been amazing the Pres president of
the school the dean or whatever like
immediately put out a statement being
like shut that [__] down we're not going
to be one of those schools so they
really haven't had you know knockwood
many incidents you know no hate crimes
and you know no swastikas drawn on the
side of a building so I felt good you
know supporting a school like that and
they all were like it's been you know
really comforting here and the toast has
been booing me so it was really honestly
fabulous like I have no complaints
that's so nice so it was University of
Georgia yes Ugg add go dogs oh yeah I no
that I know so added to the list of safe
schools for Jews and so it's a very
short list but it's an important one
yeah so ug tury approved it was just
fabulous and there were so many there
were just like nice girls like I just
loved it and then I had to rush home
because yesterday I went out to
Livingston New jyy to see my favorite
human being on Earth Mark Shon wer the
Holocaust Survivor I met last year um so
this time of year they do this thing
called Journey for the living where in
the month of November everybody tries to
walk 15 miles because on one very cold
November night in Poland many many years
ago mark his sister and his mom walked
15 miles in the middle of the night to
get to a ghetto because they thought the
ghetto was going to be like this like
only option for safety it wasn't but it
was a part of his journey in this long
very cold night um and so we walked
yesterday in New Jersey we didn't walk
15 miles cuz you know it was cold and
whatever she is who she is we walked a
mile and a half you know we started our
journey to 15 miles are you going to
complete the 15 miles this month I'm
going to try I'm going to try cool so it
was just fabulous to hang out with Mark
and I got to have lunch with him
afterwards and it was just it was a
fabulous day so that's why I didn't even
go to the game and GE I literally flew
in the morning and then out at 5:00 so I
could get back to Jersey so it's kind of
like such a busy weekend you know yes
was a busy weekend I came home I had
like a nice homesteading day yesterday
cooking up a store made a chili so good
so good I really really perfected my
personal brand of chili it's a it's a
chili day it was a chil day we had the
the game on the games uh you know there
was Frankfurt happening I watched games
uh as well and um the Cowboys played I
know the Jets played and lost did the
Cowboys win I don't know I didn't watch
but I did watch the Jets go another game
Jackie without scoring a single
touchdown whoa zero did they get a kick
in so the last couple of games they've
scored like x amount of points and every
single one of them has been a field goal
God it okay so it wasn't zero on the
scoreboard and this season this is what
they said on TV last night 50 % of the
points scored for the Jets have been
field
goals well you know what let's look on
the bright side their kicker must be
feeling really good about himself Aaron
Rogers did say his goal is to come back
by mid December and he says I know
that's crazy but when you have a great
surgon and a great patient anything is
possible I love that optimism and it
actually is a great segue for me to talk
about the fact I had a great surgeon I
was a great patient when I was pregnant
and Dr Fox I'm on his podcast again
today and this episode is all about my
pregnancy so the last one was all about
me our girl introducing myself life
story and this one is all about my birth
story and my pregnancy story so his
podcast is called the healthful woman
still we are all kind of like helping Dr
Fox in a potential Rebrand but I like
the name and you can because I like it
and he didn't go for what does the fox
say he wasn't about that okay well he's
wrong for that so you can listen to me I
mean today on the healthful woman it's
all about my story and also like you
know we get the the expert's opinion
about what was going on and it was and
his POV it was crazy to relive it I've
literally forgotten about it it feels
like so long ago I feel like that's
natural right like
you black out traumatic times like once
they're over natural for people or
natural for me people well everybody
handles Hard Times differently it's you
know hard times are more personal than
common be more personal than food more
personal than insurance so true but yet
also just like I feel like in pregnancy
in general you kind of forget how hard
it is it's like your body's way of
getting you ready for the next one so
true are you ready for the next one I am
not I am on Hiatus yeah yeah I'm not
ready for the next one either like
Theo's just kind of keeping me very very
busy yeah yeah we're on Hiatus we're
taking a break yeah um so so much went
on this weekend like obviously in our
person personal lives but also in the
world as well um I feel like it's going
to be one of those things where it's
like do you remember where you were when
you saw the kiss and the Chiefs like I
remember where I was I was watching
Gossip Girl which I've made a lot of
Headway in I'm now with the Georgina
episodes and like I want to turn it off
like when Vanessa came in I was like oh
my God I forgot about this annoying
wench like she kind of made me want to
like stop but not enough honestly feel
like I disliked her more as a child like
she's definitely weird and inappropriate
with a man with a boy who has a
girlfriend but like she's not a bad
person she's actually like kind of a
moral compass if you will I don't know
if that changes but she's a good person
she is a bit of a moral compass of the
show but she makes like being a moral
compass like so Dreadful yeah but with
Georgina oh my Ben like we can't watch
it and then it really got us talking
about the trajectory of Michelle
tractenberg career and how criminally
underrated and under booked Michelle
tractenberg is she is an
incredible actress like the way she's so
[__] evil like where you feel it in
your bones you're like this [__]
[__] like she's such a what happened to
her right but she also is the ice
princess and get you a girl who could do
both sweet as sugar sweet as sugar in
the ice princess also Harriet the Spy of
course
so SP she just has a really diverse
portfolio and I feel as though she's
super super talented where in the world
is Michelle tractenberg
let's check her IMDb maybe she's you
know been doing Indie movies but the
thing is like she is a worldclass talent
like she needs to be booking she should
be an Oppenheimer like that's how
talented she is yeah I I do agree with
that honestly she really hasn't worked
in a while don't forget about 17 Again
really good movie oh my God I forgot she
was in 17 again and Euro trip yeah Ben
was like I know her from EuroTrip and I
was like I know her from Ice Princess
but what I also know her from that not
enough people talk about is there was
like a brief period in high school where
I was obsessed with the Knicks because
like I just wanted like attention and I
like got really into it I went to a lot
of games I knew all the players and
there was a player on the Knicks called
Danilo galinari and he was probably the
most handsome man to ever walk the wor
he was Earth he was Italian he was just
not like other players you know he was
so handsome and he was like really good
and he became this New York like social
almost because he wasn't you know
world-renowned but in New York we loved
him and he very briefly dated Michelle
trackon morg and it was this iconic
moment in pop culture they broke up he
got traded I did actually meet him like
two years ago at the fena hotel in Miami
like I don't think anybody knew who he
was and I was dying we have a picture
together I was dying for meeting danilla
galinari like I was obsessed with this
man um and not enough people talk about
the very brief you know kind of shooting
star moment where he dated Michelle
tractenberg Georgina yeah yes also
definitely Michelle trenburg has been
black balled from Hollywood because she
was getting major roles and then all of
a sudden she's in Robot Chicken and
sister cities she has been blackballed
what H what is the story I need a
documentary on Michelle tractenberg yeah
also allegedly she was in the new Gossip
Girl as Georgina Sparks well last night
I was also thinking about the new Gossip
Girl and the reason why it didn't work
is because it never could have worked
the show itself like nobody knew when
the show was airing or even when they
were casting the show that it was going
to be this cultural phenomenon they
didn't know that it just happened to be
it was just a well-written well-cast
high like high budget show and it had
all the makings and they didn't know it
and then with the second show like they
were trying to recreate that and you
can't recreate something like that with
that intention those things like Gossip
Girl becoming what it was happened
unintentionally yeah also just like
nobody who is it for nobody wants it it
was bad they couldn't have had more
manpower behind it and they couldn't
have it couldn't have flopped Harder by
the way but also watching the show now I
and I'm just keeping top of Mind who
Gossip Girl is and like so far like it's
kind of possible like the episodes I
watched last night spoiler
alert was that Jenny was dating that guy
Asher but it turned out he was gay and
he really was like hooking up with Eric
yeah but he was like this billionaire
and they're like how did Jenny get him
and Dan finds finds out that Asher is
gay and he wants to tell Jenny but Blair
and Serena are like Jenny is not going
to listen to you she's only going to
listen to like girls and Gossip Girl so
he tells Gossip Girl that Eric not that
Eric that Asher is gay and of course he
told Gossip Girl because he is Gossip
Girl yes but that could also work with
different girl it could be explained I
heard a rumor that Gossip Girl Was
supposed to be Nate and and it got
leaked and switched it so watch it also
from that POV yeah okay but it's just
like insane these people are just like
talking about cocaine and then taking
the SATs like it's just not real no it's
not real also don't forget that Gossip
Girl was a book series that was
incredibly popular So when you say like
nobody knew it was going to be
successful like we all knew the books
were amazing Blake Lively was like you
know coming off of Sisterhood of the
Traveling Pants like it was on the CW
like
uh I think everybody like knew you know
that's a that's a job like if you book
that like it was a perfect storm it was
a perfect storm yeah but that's like if
you know Twilight becoming a movie yeah
nobody knew but we knew we knew yeah
that's true no it had all the makings of
a cultural phenomenon yeah because it
had an existing fan base but a lot of
things by the way some things do have
all the makings of a cultural phenomenon
and then and then they don't yeah like
Vampire Academy the movie right cuz I
think that book was popular the movie
was amazing yeah but it just didn't pop
off they actually made Vampire Academy
on peacock a series based on the book
they're like trying again I don't think
it happened
again like I said but I don't think it
needed to cuz the movie was perfect
right they didn't do anything wrong in
that it was just like kind of society
not knowing what's good which happens
all the time I feel
um as though like sitting here and not
talking about karma is the guy on the
Chiefs like I don't know what we're
doing you know and like I love to
Dilly I want you to know that you took
us on this tent Gossip Girl and then
Michelle track himberg Rabbit Hole I'm
following your lead I did I did no no by
the way I take full full full
responsibility but I I have to draw the
line somewhere you know and I think the
line list is me look I've drawn it oh
right because now I'm talking about my
passions the EMP talking about no see
see I want you guys all to see what just
happened I let her wax poetic on her
thoughts on Gossip Girl I try to talk
about one movie I liked it's time no but
by the way it's so true but it is time
like facts are facts you know it was
time when you started talking about
nonsense from 10 years ago it was time
then too no no it wasn't time cuz
honestly and I'm not being like a drama
queen when I say like people are begging
me for my Gossip Girl takes I swear to
God so why didn't you post them on your
story I did I did but you know like
something as big and
as important as Gossip Girl like
requires verbal explanation you know
yeah so get on stories and start talking
I need to reach everyone here okay well
I just want you to know what you did
there yeah no by the way like you think
I don't know like I know I'm
disgusting okay great accountability
equals taken I will accept that great
without further ad do to do too about
tur's passions and not mine here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by State Farm
the State Farm personal price plan helps
you create a plan that gives you options
so you get an affordable price and it
comes with a lot of benefits like the
coverage you want a policy that helps
cover what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences so
think about it like this what are your
music playlists podcast feeds morning
routines all have in common well they're
personal like Jackie eats 17 enormous
huge breakfast tacos every single
morning and I just have a couple of nuts
like we're so different you know so
disgusting by the way I'm doing Sakara
this week after being shamed so
everything in your life is a reflection
of you and insurance should be no
different because what is more important
and more personal than Insurance
honestly nothing not comedy not poetry
and what did we say personal trauma and
not how you recover from trauma that's
what the State Farm personal price plan
has in common it gives you options to
help you personalize your coverage so
that you can protect what you care about
most all at an affordable price just for
you so you can see more of yourself in
everything you love so if you can't
trust me you can trust Jake from State
Farm and you really can trust Jakey from
State Farm and I think we all know that
to be true so like a good
neighbor I'm saying something important
so finish what you're doing I moved my
mic only you could hear me only you got
that little teaser like a good neighbor
State Farm is there call or go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan neighbor State
Farm is there prices vary by state opt
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary today's episode is
also brought to you by Legacy box
friends and family gathering for the
holidays always brings up memories of
holidays past moments that you wish you
could go back and relive and thanks to
Legacy box now you can digitizing those
memories so you can relive moments of
holidays past is easy with Legacy box
trusted by over a million families
including ours Legacy box is simple
affordable and safe and starting now our
listeners get early access to their best
sale of the year you can digitize your
tapes for as low as $9 a tape Legacy box
is that company that all year long
everybody's like wait what was the name
of that like digitizing and now like
with the holidays coming up we get it so
much so listen up Legacy box digitize
your old tapes we did it with our VHS
tapes we had this huge box of tape
sitting in our basement honestly I
didn't even realize till we started
working with Legacy box that it's
actually really dangerous to just leave
like important things in a box because
the elements they can overheat they can
be victims of floods so take
accountability do better get your box of
vhs's your super eight films whatever
sort of era you grew up in and get them
to Legacy box the process is easy you
send in your old VHS tapes camcorder
tapes pictures and their team
professionally digitizes everything by
hand in the USA they digitize over 15
different types of media and after 10
years in business Legacy box is the
world's largest digitizer they've helped
over a million families relive wedding
days chaotic childhood Christmases and
even trips to Yellowstone so relive your
most important memories and take
advantage of Legacy Box's best sale of
the Year visit legacybox.com toast to
get early access to the Black Friday
sale and start digitizing your memories
for for as low as $9 a tape which is
overall 60% off legacybox.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by zbiotics maker of the world's
first genetically engineered probiotic
so your first drink of the night is for
a better tomorrow engineered by a team
of PhD microbiologists zbiotics is a
probiotic drink that breaks down the
byproduct of alcohol which is
responsible for rough mornings after
drinking so here's how you use it have a
zbiotics for best results make zbiotics
your first drink of the night step two
drink responsibly paste yourself hydrate
and get a good night's sleep and step
three enjoy tomorrow wake up feeling
refreshed and ready to take on the day
there's really no reason why you
shouldn't be able to have a lovely night
and then wake up feeling good refreshed
and able to be productive and zbiotics
totally understands that because they're
a preal probiotic and they are the
world's first genetically engineered
probiotic it produces an enzyme to break
down the byproduct that alcohol creates
in your body because it's this byproduct
not dehydration that's to blame for your
rough day next day so when I tried
zbiotics for the first time I had been
you know out with a few friends the
night before before and I had just
gotten it I took it before and I as
instructed I drank the bottle of
zbiotics before alcohol and I was really
amazed at how good I felt the next day
and I was how productive I was able to
be because that's the worst thing when
you're a business owner like you want to
unwind at the end of the day but you
also have to wake up the next day and
keep doing things so go to zbiotics
docomo to get 15% off your first order
when you use code toast a checkout you
can also sign up for a subscription
using our code so you can stay prepared
no matter the time or the occasion
zbiotics is backed with 100% money back
guarantee so if you're unsatisfied for
any reason they'll refund your money no
questions
remember to head to zbiotics toast and
use code toast a checkout for 15% off
thank you zbiotics for sponsoring this
episode thank you la you're welcome our
first story eras Argentina lots to
unpack Taylor Swift took her talents to
Argentina and her tour there this
weekend she performed one night very
exciting you know not two nights yeah
first night though yeah was the big one
was the big one the first one or the
second
one the second one one but there was
another one last night maybe there's
three maybe it was the second one okay
one was one was postponed for weather
right the one that was postponed was the
one that he was
at well he got there and yeah then it
was postponed so they got the night off
together yeah and then he went to the
show the next night where a lot of
things ensued first he was in the tent
with Taylor's dad dancing along taking
pictures and videos of each other next
Taylor changed the lyric and Karma from
karma is the guy on the screen coming
straight home to me to Karma is the guy
on the Chiefs coming straight home to me
then she also sang endgame as one of her
surprise songs so that's a pretty
obvious Easter egg and then when the
show was over footage was captured of
them backstage uh Travis waiting
respectfully with his hands behind his
back Taylor coming off the stage running
towards him giving him a big kiss and
then walking off arm in arm it's too
much like I don't even know where to
begin let's begin with this with the um
secret songs cuz I just have really
quick thoughts something I've noticed
about Taylor recently is like she's
really like listening to the swifties so
a lot of people were like oh my God she
has to play Endgame like they theorized
that and then she actually did it it's
possible she came to the conclusion on
her own but like with this with the next
song she did um the new Vault song is it
over now but she mashed it up with out
of the woods and literally a girl went
viral last week for being like is
anybody else hearing this and she saying
the mashup that Taylor ended up singing
so I feel like she's like leaning more
to like Swifty culture which I actually
just really appreciate because the
swifties you know they're a little
passionate a little too passionate
sometimes but they've got good ideas
yeah and I love that yeah so two very
good songs then endgame is obviously
like hopefully you know he's her endgame
but also because it's very atic themed
it's it's athletic coded so we love that
then let's talk about Scott Taylor's dad
being literally obsessed with Travis
Kelce like I've seen him in the tent I
think he was in the tent with Joe at
points maybe even Matty Healey like you
wouldn't even know that they know each
other like so distant so cold he is like
f like honestly I think he's more in
love with Travis than Taylor is like he
was wearing a Chief's lanyard around his
neck like he's obsessed he was they were
together the whole night just them to
wouldn't you be long it's three hours
he's a dream son-in-law dream son-in-law
we know Scott loves the NFL I mean he is
I believe an Eagles fan but it doesn't
matter like he respects the hustle it
doesn't matter also CU it's like the
eagles's
brother true he could be like being nice
to Travis to get close to Jason that's
very true like maybe trying to get
Jason's number from Travis's phone while
he's taking the video it's like oh I'll
take this picture of you meanwhile I'm
going through your phone he's using
Travis he's social climbing to get to
Jason I mean respect the hustle respect
the hustle like the the Glee and and
like honestly just such a shout out to
the Argentinian swifties like they were
on the ground doing the work like we
were getting content the minute it was
happening and I have to say notic
something I've noticed that just is the
sweetest thing ever when I noticed it
with Argentina but then I also noticed
it um I saw a screening from the Aros
tour in Israel is like places where
English isn't the first language but
Taylor Swift is like so beloved when you
hear the fans singing Back the song they
they have an accent and it is just so
cute like yeah it's the cutest thing
ever and it really just I think is a an
indicator of how massive Taylor Swift is
cuz these are people who don't even
speak English as their first language
and they know every single lyric and
it's just it's really amazing yeah even
when they were chanting reputation
before better than revenge and and they
had a little accent stadium has an
accent yeah it's so cute and I just like
loved it and they were just really
honestly five stars for them like they
were doing the work when it came to
getting the content to the world in real
time yes so the video of you know Karma
as a guy on the Chiefs coming straight
home to me there was a girl who filmed
it perfectly and then you see her
freaking out and you know what like when
I saw that I was like great and I put my
phone down cuz I was like that's what I
needed to see he was there I saw you
know I saw him in the tent I saw him
like like he obviously has been studying
up on her music because he knew a lot
more lyrics I'm sure he didn't know as
many as I mean there's so many um so
then I saw Karma as a guy in the Chiefs
I'm like oh okay that's what I was
waiting for and I put my phone down and
I watched Gossip Girl and oh my God
maybe 20 minutes later I checked my
phone again and I was
like the kiss the kiss the running off
stage the running up to him the big
smooch I need a body language expert on
the toast because there is if a picture
says a th000 words that video says 25
million what is it saying to you for me
it's cuz I think somebody could look at
that video and be like oh like she ran
to him and she put her arms around him
first but I think he's very respectful
of like what she wants people to see cuz
when she was offstage she was backstage
but the thing about an arena a stadium
excuse me is it's circular yeah yeah and
so people in the back can see Taylor
coming off stage she's really not fully
in the privacy of her own world until
maybe 3 minutes after she's off stage
just because she's off stage doesn't
mean she has privacy right so he knows
that she knows that and whatever she
does backstage because she always waves
to everyone people throw bracelets at
her like she knows that that's going to
be on tape so I think he was like trying
to just defer to her being like Oh are
we going to embrace here or not because
like there's literally probably 5,000
people behind us like maybe we should
wait till we get in the tent so I think
like her running to him and her putting
her arms around him and her kissing him
is not her like being more interested in
him than he is I think it's him totally
respecting whatever boundaries she wants
to put up she has famously not really
shared much about her relationships she
really hasn't even been caught kissing
her boyfriends there's a few instances
and none of them were by her own accord
it was somebody filming without her
consent there's like a blurry picture of
her and Joe in the ocean they didn't
know the camera was there there's
obviously that horrifying Harry Styles
New Year's Eve kiss that's so awkward it
makes you literally want to crawl into
your own skin I don't think she knew
anybody was filming then it's usually
Paparazzi it's usually when she thinks
she's in privacy but she's not we she
has never like knowingly kissed
someone in front of people you know yeah
I also think one he's respecting her
boundaries of how much she wants to show
of their relationship but two it's like
this was her big night like is there
anything more annoying than someone
running up to you and like making it
about them it's like wherever she wants
to go next whatever she wants to like
debrief but like him like going and
attack like no let her take the lead how
does she want to exit the arena I will
follow her lead I'm just here in
whatever capacity she wants me to be no
it's so true like what's worse than
somebody who like makes someone else a
special night about them and I feel like
he acted so appropriately it's a hard
line to walk because the whole night is
about Taylor but the second he's in the
tent everybody's turning around filming
him even when she comes on they're going
to you know film him for portions of it
how do you navigate that with like
wanting to hypee up your girlfriend not
take away from her moment but also
knowing like people are looking at you
and honestly I think he handled the
entire night perfectly like there's not
one thing I would change yeah no cuz you
want to be interested and involved but
you don't want to give people like too
much you don't want to take away but you
also want to seem interested or else
people will be like he was looked
miserable yeah so now of course
everybody Compares you know footage from
Travis at an eras tour to Joe at
reputation and at reputation Joe was
famously like wearing a hat Incognito
literally I think there's maybe one
video of him smiling like he was very
somber and now we're kind of because
Travis is just kind of being everything
that Taylor needs but also everything
that the swifties need the swifties are
now dragging Joe and I don't think
that's fair because I think Joe was very
much following Taylor's lead at that
time she did not want her rep they
weren't not public because Joe didn't
want it you know like Taylor called the
shots Taylor is Taylor so I think he was
following her lead I'm sure he was a
great boyfriend like I don't think it's
fair
to just completely drag just because
we're so excited about Travis but like I
get it like you look at the two footages
and like one of them is at the arist
toore having the time of his life and
the other one looks like he's literally
like on his way to jail like he's so Miz
yeah but also like Travis is Travis you
can't and he's not to say like Joe isn't
famous but like he he's a working actor
but he's not really a celebrity like a
lot of other actors are you know he's
he's we really wouldn't know much about
him had it not been right so like Travis
if he started acting in a way that
wasn't congruous with his personality
that we know like he's Goofy's silly
he's always dancing when he scores a
touchdown like Travis G to Travis Trav G
to tra that's an amazing Point as well
but also Joe is like a serious guy he's
like you know British fancy actor you
know he does like time period pieces
he's not going to be like shaking his
titties to endgame you know yeah but I
also think it's really not fair like Joe
was really great to Taylor he good for
Taylor really hard time like it's really
easy for Travis to come into the tent
and hype up when all they're
experiencing is love and adoration like
Joe was with Taylor through it all and I
just feel like you swifties should have
put a little more respect on his name
and you don't have to compare no you
don't have to compare you're right like
their relationship was during the tough
times like when Taylor wasn't so
universally beloved and there were
people hasht Taylor Swift is over party
the snakes like they made it through all
of that he was you're right like he was
good to her he was there for her he was
a steady force in her life 6 years it
didn't work out and that's sad but just
because like Travis is different doesn't
make Joe bad you're right yeah Travis of
course Travis is more exciting for all
of us duh but like duh but he's also so
far they've only experienced one Chief's
loss like they haven't really gone
through hardship together it's F it's
all fun and games when it's all fun and
games and I also think Taylor probably
feels this is something Taylor would
never [__] do the kiss like that just
it just goes against who she is and I
feel like because she's in this place
where she literally can't breathe
without without getting Applause like
she's reached a level that I think
people are are comparing only to Beatles
Mania like she has reached a level of
universal love respect adoration fandom
that she really can't do anything wrong
so that's probably it's not something
she's ever experienced before and it's
probably such a relief for her and it's
probably fun so it's like you know what
yeah I'm in love let me just kiss my
[__] boyfriend after I just worked so
hard on stage for 3 hours in a country
15 hours for my own that's how [__]
globally famous I am [__] yeah also
it's it's like if she if at this level
of her success if she can't act how she
wants and be how she wants you know and
just live freely authentically then
what's the point if she still has to
like worry about oh am I running too
fast am I you know too excited am I not
kissing him like live your life girl
you're really speaking like Unbelievable
Facts today you're making like really
good points thank you I love just I love
uh internalizing what the swifties are
going through and just making it more
Salient for for larger life lessons for
larger life lessons like it's true
what's the point in all of the success
if you can't just like be who you are
yeah and live and enjoy your life also
the first night she sang Labyrinth
yeah I'm falling in
love so cute so then that was the
headline Taylor sings she's falling in
love again no but it's so funny because
towards the end of the American arist
Tor like people were noticing certain
songs Taylor would sing like she was
just kind of singing them like she
wasn't feeling them lover like oh my god
that's literally a song about Joe aln
like it's become like a wedding song
it's like one of those staple love songs
and she was just kind of giving it no
love like she was doing it and she was
killing it but she wasn't feeling it and
then with certain um secret songs that
were 100% about Joe she was literally
just seeing them like her face did not
move and she just sang a song that I
think she sang as a secret song at the
end of American eras tour and like the
difference just in her demeanor it's
hilarious it's so real towards the end
the secret songs like became less
exciting and they were certainly not
coded in anything it was just like
here's a song I wrote and your guys are
going to hear it tonight yeah and then
with these Argentinian shows it was like
here are songs that mean something
different to me now right and then for
people who are still like obsessed with
Harry Harry Styles 1989 era when she did
is it over now and Out of the Woods two
songs that we know are about Harry
Styles so mixing them together just kind
of confirmed that for everyone and also
if you think about the lyrics like
they're really they're telling the same
story out of the Woods is like this
relationship like I just feel so
unstable like are we out of the woods
yet like are we good are we not good and
then is it over now it's like wait are
we literally even still together yeah so
they're very much like a thread she's
also promoting 1989 TV right she's like
so it's not even about oh I'm going to
you know I'm dating Travis and I'm going
to sing about Harry like here buy my new
album right now she's a business woman
and putting the two songs together it's
like you have to listen to two songs on
my album now right and you have to hear
the deluxe one with the new songs
Deluxe yeah
um so it was just kind of like an
incredible weekend
yeah they went out to dinner in
Argentina I think the night that the
show was cancelled they were holding
hands and the whole restroom was
cheering and there was just so many
videos of them literally walking
probably through this Corridor that was
maybe 11t long but everybody did notice
like he squeezed her hand three times
which is just like a cute thing like
boys do but squeeze my hand three times
in the back of the taxi even though that
song like I think is about Joe allwin
but whatever um so cute so obsessed and
what's so insane is that we have four
other stories we have Grammy nominations
I'm assuming we have Kylie at SNL like
so many things happen and like who cares
like it's insane to me that things that
are enormous deals like otherwise we
would be ging over literally who cares I
don't know about kaing but no but Kylie
at SNL like I literally didn't even see
a picture of Kylie at SNL until this
morning I knew she was there I heard
also like I am past the ging over Kylie
and Timothy they're just like a stable
Hollywood couple now it's yeah it's
really it's kind of crazy crazy also
have you given any thought to like what
kind of songs Taylor might be writing
right now about this like what themes
and and things what do you think and if
my and by the way I just want to say cuz
people like are like coming for me like
you said they weren't even dating like I
know I was wrong but turny took
accountability what more do you want and
then I was like against it but okay
listen I'm like stubborn and honestly
I'm probably just jealous so like get
off my back okay no but like she
literally said I was wrong and she's
done in 18 what more do you want leave
tury alone thank you um if I had to to
think cuz like for me there's so much
going on here but like it really is like
I see this whole relationship through
the lens of a smut book like I really do
like I just know Taylor's getting like
dick down in Dallas like I just know it
and I think we're going to get like some
really sexy songs like sexy very like
very sexy but what Taylor does so
brilliantly is like through the feminine
gaze like not what normal people think
is sexy but like and that's why those
Romance smut books are so popular
because it's really it's sexiness and
it's love through the feminine gaze like
we don't need to hear about like you
know what we think is sexy is different
you know yeah and I think we're going to
get like some very it's not going to be
like it's SC and hot and here no we're
going to get like feminine Gaye like you
know hand on the small of my back type
of energy that type of sexiness it's not
overt but it's very romantic and it's
very manly and that's so Travis that's
what
I but also I think we're going to get
like some pop fun cuz think about how
she's feeling right now just like on top
of the world bubbly like nothing
negative like I think I don't think
we're going to get ballads I think we're
going to get like just cheery pop kind
of like Message in a Bottle energy where
it's like you just want to pop your
[__] cuz you're so [__] happy yeah
and like just about how they're the two
they're the biggest people in the world
right now that feeling of like being on
top of the world yeah I think she's
going to sing I'm on the top of the
world looking down on creation and the
only explanation I can find that's what
I think we're going to get is the love
that I've found ever since you've been
around your love's left me on the top of
the world literally she should sample
that Taylor X the Carpenters or
or I'm on top of the world yeah yeah
also I'm on top of the world yeah love
yeah I think she'll have a song called
on top of the world I would love that
like on top of old
smokey all covered in
trees in snow
snow I left my true loved
one Ben sings that song differently he
sings on top of
spaghet all sprinkled with cheese
that's why I said lost my poor
meatball when somebody sneeze by the way
that's why I said trees you were
thinking of the other you were thinking
Taylor's version I was thinking of Ben's
version cheese right right yeah so
that's exciting to think about the next
era and like not that we could possibly
predict but what do you think the album
would be
called the thing is she never makes it
so obvious like we really can't gu but
like you could get has a a word that
might be a Cy a
cinnamon yeah cuz honestly I feel like
it would be an album a lot like lover I
know not in the aesthetic cuz I think
her aesthetic has changed so much she's
like so like sophisticated these days
like with her turtlenecks and stuff but
I do think the vibe like lover is really
like a pop album to its core and it's
also a happy album yeah so I think a lot
of the music would and I think lover is
criminally underrated we talk about this
all the time because I just think the
marketing and the the aesthetic of it
like wasn't right but the songs in and
of itself are so brilliant yeah um I
think it'll be similar to that and the
name is so simple because she was so
happy she was in just like a happy
relationship her lover so I think it'd
be simple too okay I have a few
suggestions that are coming from
thesaurus.com
Euphoria I love love love that Bliss no
oh okay um
easy Taylor's very she's very wordy oh
ecstasy I kind of like because it's also
like reference the sexual thing we were
talking but it's a little too crazy
radar okay I'm going with Euphoria even
though it be like hard for SEO because
of the show yeah even though the show's
not coming back till 2025 like she has
time to oh she has time to like to own
the word yeah to own it Lisa own
it or maybe something like like dream
Dreamland
dreamy also when are we getting crazier
when are we getting crazier Taylor's
version like it's time yeah it's really
time we've suffered long
enough
okay that would be a crazy surprise song
yeah because it's a song you just play
on the guitar it's a song everybody
knows it's a song that raised so many of
us like just do it
Wonder for an album title M no I don't
like it and she has a song called
Wonderland so okay
okay those are my predictions the thing
with Taylor like she's so much smarter
than all of us and she's like such a
like a literate person who knows so many
words you know I mean who could put only
Taylor Swift could put this in in a song
Hold on I want to remember I was it's
fun to like to put down your uh what's
the word predictions because then you
can see like how right or wrong you were
how close you were no I love to go back
like I would in a year from now when we
have an album like I would love to watch
this and laugh MC like what we got right
what we got wrong like only Taylor
schwift could use the word Mercurial in
a song about having an affair okay yeah
a dwindling Mercurial
High okay are you ready for our next
story like what's the point we still
make about Taylor actually because it's
Grammy nominations oh yeah they are here
so here are the nominees record of the
Year worship by John batist not strong
enough boy Genius flowers Miley Cyrus
what was I made for Billy ish on my mama
Victoria Monae vampire Olivia Rodrigo
anti-hero Taylor Swift Kill Bill siza so
siza leads nominations with nine
nominations she's most nominated yes um
so record of the year is like a category
that always confuses me I'm just because
there's also song of the year and a lot
of the same songs are nominated but also
song of the year is A&W for Lana Del re
antihero Taylor Swiss let's go one one
by one and like just guess for um for
each categories honestly I don't I
actually I would say Kill Bill Sissa
it's kind of frustrating that Taylor
submitted anti-hero from this album to
win every award or to be up for every
award because it's just like not as good
as other songs yeah so for record of the
year I feel like it will be um Billy
ish okay what was I made for yeah
because it's just or actually honestly
maybe flowers because that's when I
think of record of the like what song
tortured us this year like that was
everywhere but I don't feel that way
about any of these songs I feel that way
about flowers like that song now I hate
it yeah I guess it was on reals a lot
but what I do think is really kind of
crazy and impressive is that Billy ish's
nomination is a song that she wrote for
a movie like not even like from her own
album you know so maybe she'll win an
Oscar for it oh for by the way I could
see her winning an Oscar so I'm GNA say
for record of the year I am going to say
flowers and I do feel like that would be
Miley Cyrus's first Grammy yeah I'm
going to say Kill Bill yeah I I okay I
have another prediction for siza in
another category so let's go to album of
the Year okay we'll do also Victoria
Monae is she from
Victorious no oh oh no Daniela Monet on
a show called Victorious that's
confusing nope that's completely
understandable how you got to that
conclusion cool album of the Year World
music radio John batist the record boy
Genius endless wait I have something to
say I thought about it this morning cuz
boy Genius was just on SNL this week and
like I just want to say raise your hand
if you don't know who or what boy Genius
is obviously me like Phoebe Bridgers is
in it like I don't get it it's like a
band I'm so confused never heard of it
honestly okay Endless Summer Vacation
Miley Cyrus did you know that there's a
tunnel under Ocean Boulevard Lana Del
Rey the age of pleasure Janelle Monae
guts Olivia Rodrigo Midnight's Taylor
Swift SOS sizza so I think siza has a
real shot here
like like I'm not even like I don't like
actively seek out sza songs and I know
so many songs and I started to like add
her songs to my playlist from this album
like no this album was huge I think it's
going to go to siza it's either siza or
midnights like I I think guts I was
listening to in the car yesterday on the
way home from New Jersey It's [__]
amazing like it's so good but it didn't
really become ubiquitous like sour did
yeah but it's amazing it might even be
better than sour but it's so good yeah
um so I think the only and the same with
Endless Summer Vacation like it had like
two or three real Bops but it's not this
like album that everybody
digested so like unless they just choose
one of these Al like Lana Del right even
though I don't know one song on the
album and I I like they do that
sometimes John batist or boy Genius Beck
you know that sort of thing um but I do
think but if it works the way that it
should work it will be siza or Taylor
Swift but I think it will be siza
between the two of them me too um song
of the year A&W Jack antinoff anti-hero
Taylor Swift butterfly John batist Dan
the night do a Lipa flowers Miley Cyrus
Kill Bill siza vampire Olivia Rodrigo
what was I made for Billy ish so
whichever song was runner up to the
other category which I think is Billy
eish
here or Kill Bill I think Kill Bill will
win one and flowers will win the other
the Grammys likes to do that all them
like to do at these days give every
person one award like you know it's
giving participation it's giving
five-year-old like I love a sweep though
I don't think any of these deserve to
sweep the Grammys this year it's kind of
a like not a Level Playing Field I
completely agree it's not like a super
super competitive year no some years
like the folklore year it was like
everybody else should just go home like
folklore wins everything it's so obvious
even like when Casey musra won it was so
obvious yeah or like when Adele puts out
an album or Beyonce right or Bruno Mars
like okay everyone else like stay home
uh but I feel like this year it's not
like that okay I'm excited to talk about
Best New Artist Best New Artist Gracie
Abrams Fred again ice spice jelly roll
Coco Jones Noah K Kahan KH are you okay
Khan why is there like two A's Victoria
Monae the war the waren treaty I just
want to say like I'm so glad the waren
treaty is getting their
like what's the word I'm looking for
like not credit recognition they are I
saw them perform like last year at the
ACM awards they're husband and wife Duo
and they're Jackie you never heard of
two voices like this in your life and
just like sit they have like very gospel
types they have the most incredible
voices and um they like started to blow
up and then Zack Bryan did a collab with
them on his new album so like they're
really blowing up I don't think they're
going to win but like I love that
they're getting seen they're a country
husband and wife Duo and they're so cute
that's so nice but I do think Noah Khan
will win and I do think he should win I
think ice spice or jelly roll will win
okay okay next producer of the Year skip
songwriter of the Year best pop solo
performance
flowers Miley Cyrus paint the town red
DOA cat what was I made for Billy ish
vampire Olivia Rodrigo anti-hero Taylor
Swift I think flowers is going to take
it yeah and I'm okay with that yeah
um any other categories you want to go
to Country let's just do country cuz
Luke Holmes was obviously once again
slapped in the face I'm like really kind
of over this like disgusting Behavior
Luke Holmes does so much for country
music he's a global Superstar he's so
[__] unpraised he makes Incredible
music he nobody even talked about his
song during Co 6 feet apart which
literally like changed my life killed
the world nobody talks about Joe the
song he writes about you know people in
recovery like he just does so [__]
much for music he's an incredible
songwriter and I'm really honestly I'm
[__] sick of it I really yeah no it's
disgusting and why like best country not
only did he not get acknowledged in the
big categories like okay country is
always getting you know kind of pushed
to the side in his own [__]
categories he doesn't get credit like
I'm sick no and it's also weird that for
song and record of the year like neither
Luke nor Morgan songs were nominated
even though they like dominated the
Billboard charts this year no but the
thing is like Grammys is very political
and I understand why they don't want to
associate with with Mor and his Myriad
of controversy like I get it okay you
know what but let's talk about Luke
[__] combes like I've had enough no I
agree but it's like and they're both
undeniable but it's like two people that
they're just completely disregarding but
also they like for even best country
album like why isn't nominated even like
when you R down so they go by category
by genre field number four the fourth
category is jazz traditional pop musical
theater and then country like countries
underneath that country is the second
maybe third largest genre no the Grammys
do not respect the hell out of country
like know that so best country
song He's not nominated Brandy Clark
buried Chris Stapleton White Horse
Morgan Wallen last night Tyler Childers
in your love Zack Bryan featuring Casey
musra I remember everything I just feel
like this category just doesn't
represent the year of country yeah no by
the way the best country song of the
year will be last night by Morgan Wallen
it's been number one on Billboard for
right but do you think that he'll win I
saw so many like Tik toks going not Tik
toks um tweets going viral being like
Morgan Wallen has zero um nominations
like making fun of him like pop crave
and those types of accounts when then I
went to look I'm like he literally has
one yeah I mean they had like millions
of retweets it was
crazy not that we should be like you
know getting our news from Stan Twitter
accounts but like you would think for
nominations like it would be accurate
yeah uh do you think he'll win even
though like that is the country song of
the year I mean if he doesn't win it's
just very clear that like the Grammys
don't want to you know award him things
and like be associated with him because
it is the biggest song probably of the
last couple of years like it's so big so
it should win and if it doesn't I think
we know why they just don't want to like
be associated with him best country
album rolling up the welcome mat Kelsey
ballerini Brothers Osborne by Brothers
Osborne Zack Bryan by Zack Bryan Rustin
in the rain Tyler chers bellbottom
country Lany Wilson to me there's not a
clear winner I think in terms
of see like I would say rolling up the
welcome app by Kelsey ballerini but I
don't think that was the biggest in
country it just had bleed over into pop
and people it was great for country
music but I don't know if it was the
biggest country album if that makes
sense I think Laney Wilson will win me
too for the same reasons that she swept
the um C CMAs and I yeah I I for the
Grammys it's all like Optics yeah but
you're definitely right that there isn't
like a clear
um winner for any of these categories
yeah which also makes it interesting
yeah
yeah so when are the Grammys
[Music]
um February 4th wow that's in a long
time that is in a very long time it's
kind of like giving Super Bowl literally
like why are they releasing this now
yeah like calm
down are you ready for our next story
yes Kylie Jenner supports her Bo Timothy
shalam at the SNL Afterparty Kylie
attended the SNL Afterparty to support
her mans the star was photographed
arriving at the star studed event
Saturday evening in New York City
following her boyfriend's hosting duties
in the photos Kylie who have arrived
separately from Timothy showed up to the
after party party wearing a Chic all
black look sunglasses handbag looking
gorgeous cute like they're dating I
think Chris was there
too she was posting like promoting SNL
before I was even out she's like so
friendly with Lauren they're just like
besties now um cute like cute I really
don't have a lot to say here it's just
like good for them no and they are just
quietly going strong yeah it's kind of
crazy
yeah I'm I'm happy for it like nothing
to say he's I hope he's a good boy
friend to her did you see the Tik Tok of
the girl who ordered Kai and in the mail
she got a mini chainsaw no that's what
showed up in the kai box that's so weird
no I know what was it a real chainsaw or
like a toy
I oh that's a good question I think it
was real that's weird the new Kai drop
looks really cute it's all like puffers
and cat suits yeah yeah yeah it's cute
yeah I haven't bought anything no but
like maybe I'll get a puffer even though
I like my puffer but and you literally
live in Florida but we're going on a ski
trip and I could get and I could get
cold you could so maybe I need a puffer
okay like it wasn't an attack you know
it felt like one that you were trying to
stomp on my dreams of getting a
puffer are you
okay no okay I feel attacked oh well you
shouldn't I was just simply pointing out
that you live in Florida so you like
don't need a million puffer jackets I
mean okay you're being oliv I don't want
a million I was going to have two you
don't need a million like stop you have
so many you like you have so many
breakfast tacos and so many puffer
jackets it's too much over Jackie overc
consumption is
real okay so I won't get one great I
hope you're happy I'm going freeze I
hope you're happy because I've told Mom
my Char is not charging on me iPad are
you ready for our next story if it's the
next story that's brought to you by
caroway the Hol are approaching oh my
God excuse me the holidays are
approaching and you know what that means
awkward family discussions around the
table but luckily your beautiful carway
pans are sure to be the topic of
conversation let's talk about this add
it to the list Jackie so in my old
apartment I had like the tiniest kitchen
I had one carway pan I had the frying
pan like it was great yeah it was a pan
it was cleaned really well and it was
great like whatever my new so I got I
got the bake wear set I got the full
kitchen wear set I got like the food
storage set and I got the organization
I'm
obsessed like yes Jackie has been
talking about it forever sorry I haven't
had a big kitchen like you forever like
now I do now I have everything oh my God
I got okay let's talk about that the way
they know like it's made for people who
live in New York City apartments that
little thing that hangs off the door
that organizes your Lids genius oh my
God I'm obsessed my little cabinet with
all my pots and pans makes me so happy
now it's like not normal how happy it
makes me I got the sage green which I
totally complement the vibe in my
apartment you guys it's like it's like I
get it now like it's so good it's so
good it makes cooking a pleasure it
makes cleaning up easy I'm happy to
report I know I've been talking about
the pink set for a while caroway wanted
to send me a birthday present I'm
getting the pink set and I'm getting P
set it's non toxic it's easy cooking and
it's well-loved so visit carway home.com
theast to take advantage of this limited
time offer for up to 20% off your next
purchase this deal is exclusive for our
listeners and it will not last long so
visit Caraway home.com theast Caraway
nontox to cookware made Modern and it's
tury approved today's episode is also
brought to you by Skylight frames
looking for a meaningful gift this
holiday season that your loved ones will
actually use holiday gifts can be boring
because everybody gets the same things
you know candles we've all getting the
same stocking stuffers but if you're
looking to up your gift giving game this
year check out the Skylight frame for
you and your family perfect for the
person who's like difficult to buy
things for because Skylight is just
everything it is a touchscreen photo
frame that you can send photos to
straight from your phone and they will
appear in seconds you can even pre-load
photos before the boxes open so when
it's unwrapped and plugged in your most
Treasured Memories will appear it's a
perfect gift for everyone really the
perfect gift for like a grandmother a
mother an in-law if you have a baby and
your in-laws live across the country you
can always be like updating them with
photos it's great for new parents it's
like a baby book or a time capsule that
was that will beautifully display each
and every special moment the touch
screen makes it easy you could swipe
through photos you could tap to see new
photos that are sent and you can even
tap the heart to give like a little like
and it's super easy to set up even if
you're not Tech friendly it can set be
set up in less than 6 6 seconds it looks
beautiful in your home they have new
color options to match any style and
it's really like better than social
media you can use the free app to send
and scroll through photos and display
photos without Wi-Fi satisfaction
guaranteed they're confident that you'll
love the Skylight that they're offering
you a free 120-day returns and um over a
million people love the Skylight frame
they've got thousands of five star
reviews and you'll love it too so as a
special limited time offer for our
listeners get $15 off your purchase of a
skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com toast to get $15 off
your purchase of a skylight frame go to
skylightframe.com
toast that's SK y l i g HT f r m.com
toast it is one of my favorite things to
give people but it's also my favorite
thing to have in my house cuz I don't
love a million chachkies with like a
million different photos so one frame a
million photos what's what's bad what's
what's wrong with that love it our next
story Nicki Minaj is on the cover of
vogue's December issue opening up about
her plastic surgery regrets she says I
was fine just the way I was so Nicki
joined run through with Vogue podcast to
discuss her new cover for the magazine
along with motherhood and why she
regrets getting plastic surgery so Vogue
has a podcast now yeah I guess
accompanying with their magazine like
and it's called run through run through
with Vogue that's kind of a good name
like the run through yeah and it's good
when they have like their cover star on
to talk you know more in depth about the
cover yeah that's like something they
should have done like a little while ago
like when you when you want to be on the
cover of Vogue obviously everybody wants
to be on the cover of Vogue and so when
you get someone major they obviously now
make them agree to like 73 questions
there's like a whole list in addition to
the interview and the cover so having a
podcast go along with that is a great
idea but like they really should have
done this like two years ago yeah well
sorry tury and you know what actually
maybe they did like maybe we didn't know
about it let's see when the podcast
started and is it like a monthly podcast
or a weekly podcast um I'm gonna I'm
going to let you know it is
weekly they have like 65 episodes oh so
maybe it was 2 years ago well no 65
weekly would be like a little over a
year ago a little over a year okay I see
corrected so she's on the podcast
talking about her plastic surgery regret
saying I guarantee you if you change
anything on your body and do anything
Surgical and all this you're going to
more than likely not definitely more
than likely look back one day and say I
was fineing just the way I was she told
the host and that's what happened to me
I could not believe even some of the
photos that I didn't love she opened up
about her reason for going under the
knife in the first place saying I didn't
like being skinny having a flat butt
having boobs that didn't sit high enough
it was a lot of things she added that
she used to shy away from looking at old
photos of herself as she was never
satisfied with her appearance now she
shared I love the way that person looks
physically she believes her son helped
change her tune she said I think
pregnancy could have played a role
because seeing my son did remind me of
myself so much my real self and it made
me think why didn't I like this so weird
but seeing old photos being able to look
at old photos again made me realize
those old photos are beautiful she
recently underwent breast reduction
surgery a decision she talked about in
her V cover story she said I love it I
used to want a bigger butt and now I
look back and realize how silly that was
love your curves and your love your non-
curves there's nothing wrong with any of
it oh my I first of all I love this
message I think I think we hear this a
little bit from people but her she's
being like really honest some people say
like oh I wish I didn't do you know
surgeries but she's saying I wish I
didn't do but she's being very she's
giving details yeah which I think is
really very honest and I really respect
this whole conversation I think it's a
great message and I think this trend
it's not happening a lot but I feel like
Kylie talked about it but she doesn't
appear to be like undoing a lot of that
stuff but she talked about how becoming
a mom made her like question some of the
decisions she made when she was younger
black China she's completely undid
everything and I think she looks even
more beautiful than she ever looked I
love this I really do yeah Molly May
talks about this in her book how she
like kind of overdid it with the filler
and how she just wishes that she'd never
did and I think it's it's really easy to
get carried away with this stuff and you
really are perfect just the way and if
you want to do something I would sit on
it for a very long time not just really
bothers you a month six months years I
would wait years yeah and make sure that
it's what you want to do because I think
for a lot of celebrities they go back
and forth and it's easy for them but for
the average person like it's not that
easy
so much money you take so much off of
work to recover it's not like you can
just go in and out of the doctor's
office yeah so I think it's really good
that she's sharing this message and also
like Trends do change and then you're
kind of stuck with something no it's so
true I feel like for the last couple of
years like the curvy trend has been like
so popular but I feel like we're going
more like if you're look at like Trends
and fashion and celebrities like now
everyone's going for like the skinny
aesthetic and like if you just spend all
this time money on a new ass yeah only
to look out of style a year later yeah
you don't want insane to make permanent
changes to your body that might be out
of fashion yeah so um also the pictures
from the shoot are beautiful she's
really like in her fashion minimalist
era love and I'd love this era for her
me too I like really love Nicki Minaj
like You' done a 180 I know I know I
like I know she's problematic like and
can we just like move on like who is it
it's so true I just love ever since she
like went on the pomac reunion and like
I just love people who don't take
themselves so seriously you know and
just have fun like you're famous and
you're rich and you can do whatever you
want like just have fun like if I was so
so famous like yeah like I would
literally show up to Bravo cotton like
you know what I mean like I just I love
people who don't take life so seriously
yeah and she's always like tweeting like
nonsense like I just appreciate the
unseriousness of it all yeah and so many
celebrities like keep their real self
like so hidden so scared to step out of
bounds everything that they do is just
so curated and boring and I'm bored no
it's true not bored by Nicki Minaj cuz
she's just so unserious and she's so
funny and she I love and you know the
fact that I don't think every cover star
does the podcast but she like loves to
talk she has like Queen Bee radio she
does like apple music radio like she
loves to talk she has an like she has a
personality and she has something to say
so I feel like I kind of love that she
did the podcast cuz not everyone would
podcasting is not for everyone no it's
not you have to have something to say
yeah so December cover star love that
for her are you ready for our fifth and
final story yeah because you know Crispy
Cream doesn't give out a free donut
without us mentioning it no it's so true
let me guess what they're doing it for
now let me think you you know think back
to this morning in our group
chat you'll get it you know what today
is World kindness day crispy K cream is
giving out free three dozen donuts today
for World kindness day oh wow a whole
dozen yep crispy K cream is giving out a
free dozen in honor of world kindness
day but there's a catch you have to do
like a Mitzvah only the first 500 guests
visiting gispy cream shops in the US
will get the sweet promotion and walk
away with a dozen free donuts no
purchase necessary so by the time this
episode comes out I'm sure your local
Crispy Cream has already met 500
customers I don't know I don't know if
you live this why you move to a small
town or if you're on the west coast
small town on the west coast go get your
free donuts yeah if I lived in like a
very small town that just happened to
have a random Crispy Cream oh my God it
would be over for you [__] I'd put
them out of
business um I just feel like people
might think we're kind of like Crispy
Cream industry plans because like we are
we are they don't make a PR move without
us like making it a fast five
story yeah but that's because they're
constantly innovating they're constantly
like on
Trend and I'm I'm sorry and they're
constantly giving away
Donuts yeah and we're going to reward
good behavior like you're giving away
free food love you bye no and like this
podcast we appreciate that you guys take
the time to listen to it and like in
return we will let you know on any given
day where you can get a free donut right
right right it's honestly an it's an
exchange of services like you listen we
give right so happy National World
kindness day naal okay Jackie in the
spirit of world kindness day
okay why don't you say something nice
about me and I'll say something nice
about you that's so nice it's also like
kind of a joke that it's World kindness
day like the world could not be nastier
it couldn't be a nastier Place filled
with filled with unkind people who are
probably celebrating World kindness day
and thinking it's about them no let's be
real let's talk about like the people
who actually like engage in World
kindness are some of the most miserable
[__] on the planet people who use the
word kind I find are some of the worst
people actually I'm going to disagree
with you there because you know as a
person who talks a lot for for a living
I find that I'm always looking for new
words because I hate to say the same
couple of words over and over again and
I feel like the word kind is actually
underrated in the sense like when you
want to describe someone as nice the
word nice is just so BL sure you really
if somebody is genuinely like a nice
person to describe them as kind I think
is actually a much more impactful word
no I totally agree that's not what I'm
talking about but like I feel like a
there's like campaigns you people who
post on Instagram being like be kind
vote with kindness yeah like kind you're
right it is it's kind of a a shield
people hide behind it's such a shield
like they those people who post about
kindness are the least kind people
describing someone as kind fine that's a
very nice word it's the same way I feel
about people who like post about like he
and like women's issues are some of like
they oh my God they'll they're so
[__] nasty to other women right or
silent about the mass rape of women in
Israel well that's for damn sure yeah
those clowns are exposed like come at me
again with your hory hory come at me
again on International women's day I do
love Herer like we've kind of made it
our own people who use it in like a
serious way like no like but but people
who use it like we do it's funny and
like her I'm obsessed yeah no agreed so
how do we go about getting a free donut
just you know asking for a friend one of
the first 500 guests to visit crispy K
cream but no I want to go back to your
exercise for World kindness day I'm
going to say something kind about you
I'm going to say something kind about
you like a big kindness or a small
kindness cuz I think sometimes small
acts of kindness are very meaningful
whatever you want I love your sweater
tur do you look beautiful and
radiant oh I wasn't like I didn't mean
it like like that I meant like
um I meant like you say something kind
about someone like oh like I was going
to say you're a great mom oh that's so
nice I was just giving you talk about my
sweater I was giving you a small
compliment okay so I have a nice sweater
and you're a brilliant mother I'm so
glad that we did this you should have
first I said big Compliments are small I
asked the question but no it's
fine and actually my sweater is from a
new toe sponsor that I've become
obsessed with I think we've done one ad
for them so far but I think they have
more coming up and not enough people
talk about
Loft not enough people talk about Loft I
just got like a whole new wardrobe from
Loft especially for our trip I got like
a bunch of cozy knit items and this
quarter zip that's hot pink is from Loft
and I'm just like none of people talk
about Loft it's not your grandma's Loft
you know Claud I'm going to show you
something
pornographic oh
okay oh wow look at that picture of the
dut looks like a butthole and honestly I
want to eat it so so it was pornographic
after it was pornographic oh my God look
at these closeups no for real it's at
the end of the show it's almost go to
your Crispy Cream honestly I should even
though like my local Crispy Cream is
like a tourist destination cuz it's in
Time Square not a donut left in sight no
no but if you are on the west coast in a
small town go get your free dozen give
them out to people for well kindness day
try and be kind even though it's so hard
for so many of you today's episode is
for the small toown West Coast girls
isn't every episode
no I feel like it is because I like it
mhm and because we come out so early on
the west coast like they're living the
dream out there yeah but like why the
only the small town
girls got you there because I like it oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh because you like it
okay okay yeah so happy world kindness
day
everyone don't forget to punch someone
in the face
today don't forget to be a nasty
[__] in celebration of world kindness
day um that is our show I'm starving now
like I have to eat something I have my
Sara lunch waiting for me
yum you make fun of me when I eat tacos
and make fun of me for I can't do
anything right around I have my tury
warm bouet
today yum thank thank you guys so much
for listening to the toast londay
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
life stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feele to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
Spotify iTunes T public radio radi cast
boox all the places web listen to
podcast find us to about a beautiful
standing and goodly talented we are are
you going to say
something love you bye
bye